Speaker 1: In his latest orange rant, the
failed former and wannabe future president
Donald Trump is promising mandatory homeless
camps.
He looks completely disoriented.
He looks swollen as usual, his right eye almost
completely shut.
But he says that he will ban homelessness.
Hey, who knew homelessness had such a simple
solution?
Just ban it.
By the way, Ban the virus while you're at
it, let's get rid of everything.
And he says that there will be tent camps
for the homeless outside of cities.
This is so deranged.
We heard him talk about it at rallies, but
it is now being put out as an actual idea
of of policy, if you can call it policy for
Trump's 2024 run.
Let's take a look at this, then I'm going
to talk to you about the ugly dystopian history
of camps for people.
Speaker 2: Ban urban camping.
Wherever possible.
Violators of these bans will be arrested,
but they will be given the option to accept
treatment and services if they're willing
to be rehabilitated.
Many of them don't want that.
We'll give them the option.
We will then open up large parcels of inexpensive
land, bring in doctors, psychiatrists, social
workers and drug rehab specialists, and create
tent cities where the homeless can be relocated
and their problems identified.
But we'll open up our cities again, make them
livable and make them beautiful.
Yeah.
Ben Urban can't.
Speaker 1: Cillessen pretending to take this
seriously for a second.
I'm not big on tent cities and there is a
lot of historical precedent for these sorts
of camps being some of the ugliest things
that societies do.
I mean, not only is it inhumane and violates
basic human rights, it also doesn't work.
And I always think it's important when we
talk about these things, to talk to those
who might support such a policy, not only
ideologically, but also pragmatically.
So the first problem is that banning homelessness
in this way, it assumes that homelessness
is a choice or a behavior that you can eliminate
with the right punishment.
And that's a flawed assumption at its core.
It ignores that homelessness has so many complex
factors that causes it.
Poverty is, of course, part of it.
It's simple to say, well, poor homeless people
are poor.
Poor people are more likely to become homeless.
Yes, that's absolutely true.
Mental illness is a component.
Addiction is a component.
Lack of affordable housing in cities is a
component.
Lack of effective public transportation that
can link lower income residential areas with
areas where the jobs are is a factor.
I could go on.
There's so many different factors.
But what the takeaway should be is if you
just criminalize homelessness, it doesn't
really solve anything.
So when you try to ban homelessness and you
try to force homeless people to live in a
tent camp outside of a city where I guess
they would be bused to it, once you're there,
there's no jobs.
You're in the middle of nowhere and there's
a tent camp and that's it.
You're doing nothing to address the underlying
conditions that got people to be homeless
in the first place.
But what you do is you further marginalize
them.
You stigmatize the homeless population because
you're actually separating them as they go.
If you're homeless, you're being brought out
there to the camp where you have no shot at
getting a job.
I mean, forget about it and you actually perpetuate
the problem and make it even worse.
Now, if you want to look at some historical
examples of this type of approach to homelessness,
there are many historical failures in the
20th century.
Many countries implemented mandatory institutionalization
programs for homeless people.
And the idea was we're going to provide shelter
and treatment, which is arguably a good a
nice thing, right?
I mean, when Trump says we're going to get
people things that they need, we'll get them
shelter, we'll get them food, we'll get them
treatment, at least on an interim basis, once
we've completely separated them from society.
We know from the 20th century examples that
they end up being overcrowded, unsanitary,
abusive, very little effective treatment provided,
stigmatizing and alienating and segregating
so it doesn't actually accomplish anything.
And what you end up with is with many of these
homeless folks essentially trapped in these
places for years with conditions they may
have worsening chances of reintegrating into
society, dramatically decreasing.
And meanwhile, the homeless population continues
to swell.
Another example of this is looking specifically
at tent cities to house homeless populations.
In the early 2000s, there were cities in the
Pacific Northwest that established some tent
cities for homeless people.
And the idea is temporary shelter.
Temporary shelter.
And exactly what I just described to you is,
is what took place.
They became overcrowded, they became unsanitary.
They weren't even properly funded.
There was limited access to basic amenities.
Running water was scarce, Sanitation facilities
were leaving much to be desired.
And they actually became hotspots for crime
and drug abuse, which only made the problem
worse.
Marginalized people stigmatized them.
And you're not making it more likely that
there will be what Republicans like to describe
as productive members of society.
So instead of punishing with further marginalizing
programs for a population that's already vulnerable,
we should instead be working towards what
causes the homelessness.
What?
Imagine you say, Hey, look.
All these homeless people.
Let's not even think about what made them
homeless.
Let's just ship them off in bus busses to
the desert and have them live in tents indefinitely.
Until what?
Until what happens?
So poverty, lack of affordable housing, lack
of support for people in their communities
rather than by separating them.
These are the types of things that will help
people reintegrate into society.
And many of these programs that are proposed
and often underfunded, they're actually quite
revenue neutral because, yes, they cost money.
But if you care mostly about the finances,
they eventually generate government revenue
by getting some fraction of those people back
to work, paying taxes, spending money in the
community.
So there's even a fiscal conservatism argument
to be made.
Swollen Trump, though I don't think he's ready
to have this conversation